I got all these voicemails from you how
many did I leave there's five five
voicemails yeah man I'll play it on the
thing hey Ben it's Cody here uh Cody Co
I'm sorry to bug you I'm on my stupid
honeymoon with my dumb wife she's boring
me so much she won't stop talking about
being married now honestly I just wanted
to talk to my guy like I'm married now
but I feel so lonely I don't know if you
were drunk had too many mimosas but it
continues hey Ben it's Cody haha in case
you didn't recognize the number I don't
know if you're mad at me but you still
aren't answering your phone who are you
with I'm still with wife I mean Kelsey
same thing so I think your machine cut
me off on the last message so I'm
calling again okay here's the last one
you sent Ben Cody oh man this is
embarrassing
this honeymoon is killing me man wife
won't stop asking me to cook her
breakfast anyway I just ran a thousand
miles and wanted to see if you're
impressed my legs are so huge now I said
that already I feel funny I think wife
put something in those eggs love you
dude yeah man it was a crazy trip yeah
wow a thousand miles